وحش طائر يهدد الصين
وقد يردع قواتها بالمحيط الهادئ كما تزعم
امريكا انها النسخه الاكثر شراسه من
الطائره اف 15 فمع احتدام سباق التسلح بين
بكين واشنطن خصوصا بعد التوترات حول
الجزيره التايوانيه طورت الولايات المتحده
هذا الوحش الطائر
المقاتله اف 15 اي اكس ايجل2 التي اكملت
اختباراتها مؤخرا فوق خليج المكسيك
مواصفات قتاليه مرعبه لهذه الطائره
القديمه الحديثه التي حلقت لاول مره في
سبعينيات القرن الماضي عام 1972
لكن النسخه المطوره منها اف 15
اصبحت تحمل 12 صاروخ جو جو في وقت واحد
وتقطع مسافات هائله دون الحاجه للتزود
بالوقود كما باتت قادره ايضا على حمل
صواريخ فرط صوتيه تفوق سرعتها نحو خمسه
اضعاف سرعه الصوت اي ما يزيد على سته الاف
كيلومتر في الساعه
خبراء عسكريون امريكيون يقولون ان مميزات
هذه الطائره تجعلها تنفرد عن اي طائره
منافسه وهي قادره على ردع خصومها في
المحيط الهادئ فمن يمكنه الانتصار هناك هو
من يمتلك قدره على اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
الشرسه تهدف الاسلحه التي تفوق سرعتها
سرعه الصوت الى مهاجمه اهداف ذات قيمه
عاليه وحساسه للوقت
كل هذه الاهداف العسكريه الحاسمه والحساسه
تقع في مناطق سواحل الصين التي تتمركز
فيها قوات هجوميه تابعه لبكين تهدد تايوان
ما جعل الولايات المتحده تقر بانه لابد من
نشر قوات ضخمه بما يكفي لتهديد بالقضاء
على جزء كبير من القوات الصينيه المهاجمه
فالقوه الجويه ضروريه لوقف اي نشاط بحري
في المحيط الهادئ والطائره المطوره اف 15
لديها القدره على ذلك فهي تمتلك سجلا
خاليا من الهزائم
لدينا الكثير من القدرات التي لا نعلن
عنها ومن الافضل ان تكون الصين حذره
هذا التهديد المباشر من قبل
رائح الجو الامريكي جاء في معرض الكشف عن
المقاتله اف 15
المتطوره وقد يحمل هذا التهديد رساله
مفادها ان على الصين ان تفكر مرتين قبل ان
تتخذ اي خطوه عدائيه تجاه تايوان